ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show god do i love these two fat
[ __ ]
they are my two favorite people i can't
believe i met them in real life
we had a d was the dinner good oh dude
dude dinner was great thank you you
really splurged you spent some money on
it i spent six hundred dollars
was it really it was postmates
do you know if you spend 600 on post
mates you go on a list
like i'm going to get denied
end of life care
because i spent 600
but we got two porter houses at the boa
steakhouse and we got uh thai
chicken wings truffle mashed potatoes
and truffle crab gnocchi and this that
truffle french fry i mean come on we did
it big we did it big the great uh
chelsea lynn
trailer trash tammy libby higgins
is with us you just completed a tour how
many cities you guys do oh i don't even
know dude i don't i don't know a lot
yeah we were on the road for three and a
half months before that we had a month
off and then we were on the road for six
months so we've been at it for all you
know nine ten months and you're just
[ __ ] you your fans are going crazy
they love it you guys are online
you know i first became aware of you
with the the video you did about the
mcrib
which was brilliant thank you um which
everyone should go check out right now
if you haven't seen it uh which about 10
million people have seen it so if you
haven't you should see it and uh and i
of course know chelsea and
you kind of got big
doing all kinds of different [ __ ] yeah a
little bit of everything little little
mukbang action mm-hmm right amazing the
tick tock the vine the instagram i'm i'm
everywhere yeah you can't get rid of me
you're out there and you and you know
you wear around a knife and fork
obviously yeah which is what i love
about you and what you dude i'm so happy
to be here just three fat guys just
hanging out absolutely talking
enjoying life exactly um because we have
three four years left right
so i have two tops yeah well that's true
well let me stop selling yourself short
well i mean
two years tops yeah is that what they
say that's what they say online
oh they're they're mean online you're
doing great
you're fine you'd be surprised that i
don't have diabetes that's what they say
well you know i i just had a cardiac
test a calcium scan and i don't have any
uh deposits in my uh heart i'm fine i'm
good too you know a lot of it is
genetics that's the ultimate equalizer
ben could drop dead it's genetics and
that's what's what i love
is genetics which is why we're going to
spend the next hour talking about my two
favorite topics race and genealogy i'm
kidding it's a joke we're kidding
um
when you're on the road are you
is it hard to not
uh
you know eat like wildebeests like wild
boar
just tearing apart a tourist that you
found late on a beach at night is that
the way because i see the way you
descend on an applebee's i mean like
vicious pirates trying to rape the
town's women yeah i mean it's tough
yeah out there oh dude i well number one
i hate fast food and that you know might
come to a shock to a lot of people
because i am large so yeah i would love
but that's all you can eat on the road
so we [ __ ] hate it so we're we
usually eat like once a day just so we
don't have to that's what you said
earlier you eat once a day that's
fascinating to me yep you don't have
time to eat right
now
that one time a day
[Laughter]
10 15 000 calories
do you make it count yeah
make it count i don't want to be hungry
till tomorrow when is it when you eat
usually if you do once a day when do you
do it at the club i like to do it before
a show three four o'clock three to five
nice yeah
nice yeah so you're up there you have
the energy yep but we do have an after
show snack while we're laying in bed
next to each other yeah we will we'll
have like a after yeah maybe a little
debbie or something yeah yeah well fans
fans bring what's your little treat like
i used to like to have uh you know a
nice gas station yodel
but like or or a little uh a little uh
you know a little cupcake with the
squiggly icing but i would love a yodel
or a ho ho when i was a young uh child
in a middle school i'd have like a
frozen uh a ho ho or a frozen yodel and
there's just something nice about that
with little cold milk
you know what my go-to snack is yeah
funyuns with bean dip and a chocolate
milk yeah
you're what they call a problem
uh you're what they call a problem
funyuns with bean dip and a troll i was
in hampton so we had a i had a great
chocolate milk it was so good
uh fresh uh farm
chocolate milk you know with with the
fun now you grew up in oklahoma yeah i
grew up in oklahoma and your parents
were not super involved well my parents
were methods right alcoholics meth heads
uh were you around them as uh a youth
yeah i got we got taken away when i was
12. wow um because i don't know where my
dad was mom got arrested for hot checks
yeah i remember that i know some id
theft and some i knew some fun people
mm-hmm uh when when i was after uh doing
cocaine as a teenager
and uh and some people did get in
trouble for that yeah a couple little
credit card getting cute yeah it was a
big thing that was a big thing right hot
checks and then they came and they get
mommy she went to jail um went to go
live with my grandma and we just stayed
you know [ __ ] yeah the grandma holds it
together barely barely right barely you
know what's sad though you can't write a
hot check anymore no it's hard you just
can't you can't even do it you can
barely pay for you can't even pay for
anything with a check it's crazy a hot
check now would would did they tell you
that when you were young when you were
12 did they say mommy wrote a hot check
oh yeah that's why we got a game
oh did they sit down and go here's the
deal there's real checks and hot shacks
guess which one your mother wrote you
know
oh we knew about everything my parents
were in jail off and on my whole life we
always knew about everything and you're
from oklahoma this is reality in
oklahoma not for everybody not for
everybody but for the majority of people
for most they live in oklahoma most
people are on math they're writing hot
tracks they're living yeah they're
living on the on the uh you know on the
other side of the law they're five to
ten miles out running the cops they're
just you know the lights are always
behind them in the distance it's a
renegade life it's a corn meth renegade
life right at least where i'm from
honestly what it is that's just what it
is it's a casino life yes people work at
a casino
their life goal is to win some money at
a casino in a room where they can smoke
yeah yeah exactly it's beautiful yeah
and you wanted out of that life you
looked around and said this isn't for me
i want to do something else because
otherwise you would have continued to
work at the sonic or the casino yeah i
worked at sonic for eight years yeah
yeah man but i never thought i never
thought i'd be doing this right this
just kind of happened me neither really
never yeah i i i thought i was going to
be stealing old people's houses which is
what i wish i was doing
to be honest with you because it's a
better job yeah yeah
job it's there's more longevity it
there's less puts less miles on the body
there's less travel i don't know how how
i ended up here because i totally
thought i would yeah i don't know man
it's wild my job is to call people like
you and get you and your friends in
oklahoma to buy like houses like
double wides on a foundation and i would
do the mortgages for how easy was that
it wasn't hard really because you would
call places and i'd be like hey do you
want a house and they'd be like what
and i'd be like you're qualif you
qualify for all this money
and then people got people did that
people got it for many many years it
were many many years and it's coming
back
the armed loans are coming back and
we're proud because get an article up
please do something we're proud well
here's the deal the interest rates are
high yeah and people are uh priced out
of the market so they're now running
these uh articles because americans have
very short attention spans and they love
uh you know man caves and pools and all
the good stuff so what they're basically
saying now
is that the actual arm loan the arm the
adjustable rate mortgage may need to
make an appearance here here we go
uh adjustable rate mortgages have risks
but
can save you money and demand for them
has tripled since
january when the rates uh started
creeping up so everybody back to square
one
that's what i say there's no life's
nothing with a little bit of a gamble
and see that kind of an article i'd just
skip over i don't even know what any of
those words mean yeah yeah just click
off now where do you live the great
libby higgins i live in st louis
missouri now [ __ ] yeah
and everybody says that's the next place
uh-huh
no no i'm kidding no one has ever said
it or like
maybe someone said that like early 1900s
yeah that's probably but you're all
headed to nashville nashville the center
of the world now you love it down there
yeah [ __ ] yeah yes and and you're
building a compound we bought a hundred
acres
i'm gonna build a house
um a podcast studio a softball field
um i've got a roller rink oh god a
roller rink this is the dream yeah
this is [ __ ] awesome to hear 106
acres yep i'm gonna pull up an old uh
just a single wide trailer yeah i'm
gonna do it up real nice that's gonna be
my movie set for trailer trash tammy i'm
gonna film there
um i won't ever have to leave unless i
you know want to go to applebee's it's a
great it's a great idea to be to be
that's so ambitious
uh to do to want to build more than just
a home
you want to kind of build a community
yeah
and i would love to do that the problem
is i am surrounded by the most
undeserving blood suckers
[Laughter]
i mean the lowest of the low the least
talented
most dishonest
vengeful petty vindictive untrustworthy
scumbags yeah present company excluded i
guess
um so for me to even in my own mind
think about investing my time my money
my energy into building a community that
would only be populated by the literally
the worst of the worst
just people fleas ticks you know you
just need to be on your own deserted
island i just kind of like i like a
a sparsely furnished cold house on a
cul-de-sac with a lot of other newly
developed houses where no one's really
home and you don't know if it's a
government testing facility
or if it's an actual neighborhood i like
a fake neighborhood where you go is this
a movie set
i like something like that that feels
uh like that easy fake neighborhood easy
come easy go yeah you know what when now
you're living with grandma is great
grandma's not on meth no okay um but she
was crazy yes what do you mean by that
what is that how do you even how do you
even discern that in oklahoma well so i
had two grandmas and so i would go back
and forth um were they were they
lesbians or just different sides of the
family no and i was just about to say
they were not lesbians okay because that
did sound like they were lesbians i had
two absolutely which would have been
cool honestly great sitcom would have
been being made right now yes they're
lesbians and they're from oklahoma their
kids are on meth but they're fun
oh my god um yeah live with grandma you
know i don't know um she was hard to
live with
um
she's still alive we don't have much of
a relationship wow um the whole um
like what i do now
uh kind of weird words are weirded
around and you mean succeed yeah well
because she was used to raising her kids
and grandkids
you know like but isn't this better what
you're doing now than had you gone down
the road of math
i'm having hot checks i'm having a good
time but is there a little bit of her
that's like resentful or yes okay yeah
yeah and now my family resents me here's
how i deal with it i attack them
mercilessly on the show every single
week and a bonus episode on the patreon
[Laughter]
is that maybe is that
that seems to be a good way to handle it
i like it i like that yeah yeah but but
here here's the thing i do believe like
i kid i do believe in healing mm-hmm and
have you ever tried to sit down and go
listen you may not see eye to eye with
me
but i want to let you know i am grateful
for what you did and thank you oh yeah i
actually have done that i did that a
couple years ago and she uh she yeah
still wasn't having it she didn't she
said go [ __ ] yourself funny yeah yeah
yeah wow so it's all right i'm i'm
chilling dude i'm having a good time
yeah you don't have to dwell on [ __ ]
like that libby higgins do you even have
a family they're all dead
i mean
they're all dead i mean i don't god
do you even i mean i'm imagining
anyone connected to you in any way i
feel like you look like a girl who just
burned down an orphanage and got on a
boxcar it's like you know one of those
trolleys and just left town but i could
be wrong i have a sister but everyone
else is pretty much dead god blessed now
what happened to them they're just
old and dead
the genetics you spoke of i know
you mean you look like we're related and
everyone we know died in a tornado
yes
everyone we know is strewn across the
wreckage i'm waiting for you to show up
on my 23andme i know i i i should i hope
i do close relative to and what does
your sister do
she lives in a missouri and doesn't
i she doesn't do any of this that no
she's very funny but she's very afraid
of the limelight yeah play a little bit
of libby higgins the uh
mcrib
the very funny mcrib sketch you know
what can i say something like that don't
don't don't give us uh uh what do you
call it ben don't give us a strike or
don't don't uh copyright claims yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah libby almost did not
post that mcrib video she she sent it to
me
and she said i don't know if i want to
post it and i said [ __ ] this is going
viral you better if you don't post it
i'm posting it the reason i didn't want
to post it is because i said the
location just because i was improving
right and i knew that it was going to
cause them problems and it didn't and it
did well what does it caught what kind
of problems people call there people
send [ __ ] there that's fun if you work
at mcdonald's you work at mcdonald's
problems are solutions like each all
your fighting is boredom so right not
for the mcdonald's endorses oh they were
so mad at her every time she came
through the drive-through they were mad
like don't come back here anymore really
oh you would still go back oh yeah it
was my mcdonald's oh that's ballsy yeah
yeah
that is ballsy this is the great libby
higgins here
god it's so good i have an announcement
to make to y'all
to the people of america
i was at this here mcdonald's on dorset
it's uh monday night
i was just disrespected in there almost
got in a fight with the gal in there
first of all my first issue is the
drive-through was filled all the way up
and i had to walk inside
so then i'm you know i'm already mad
because i got to get out my car and go
inside so i go inside i politely say hey
um can i have a mcrib meal
large size with the dr pepper
and the lady says
okay uh that'd be
6 58.
i said ain't you forgetting something
ma'am
and she said well what
i said you're supposed to offer me the
extra mcrib for a dollar when you buy
the mcrib meal
you ain't gonna believe it she looked
me up and down
and she said well don't look like you
need the extra mcrib
excuse me [ __ ]
i throw punched that [ __ ]
i knocked her ass down
so if you come to the
dorset mcdonald's and you see a lady
named charlene in there
tell her carla sent ya and then you
throw puncher or punch her in the cooter
i don't give a damn
this is against my civil rights
[ __ ] you mcdonald's
on dorset not all the other ones i like
all the other ones
brilliant [ __ ] that's amazing really did
you have a video of chelsea where it
kind of popped for you was there
something that oh yeah i don't i don't
know if anything's on youtube um oh yeah
i did a video my first viral video was
like in i don't wanna 2014 15. um where
i was i walked up to a car and asked for
a cigarette there it is down there on
the list
there it is cigarette where oh
cigarette oh
and this is the first one right there
the second one and listen by the way
yeah oh it's like a review oh by the way
i almost didn't post this video because
i thought it was the dumbest [ __ ]
thing i didn't think it was funny i
didn't think but i hadn't posted in a
minute so i needed something to post and
it just went like [ __ ] insane what
did you
when you started [ __ ] around online
and just doing stuff what made you do it
boredom right i had you know people
underestimate that you know when
everybody talks about how they figured
something out
people talk a lot about
you know inspiration all of these things
that clearly to a degree of matter you
know what people really leave out
boredom
is huge it's a big motivating factor the
reason that
we started doing this podcast is i got
bored with a lot of other things i was
doing and i still kept doing those other
things but like i felt like i was
hitting a wall creatively i needed to do
another thing something else add to it
and boredom's big
yeah i just you know when i started vine
in 2013 nobody there were no influencers
there were nobody was doing you know so
i never thought anything would come of
it i never thought i'd be doing it full
time or comedy it was just fun to you
know you were having fun yep yep i had
three followers and a reba t-shirt and i
just went to town that's [ __ ] amazing
this is and now let's take a look at
your dude yeah
up at the top yeah i think so okay
that's a thug you all got a cigarette um
we don't smoke [ __ ] off
[Music]
that like
[Laughter]
that went mega viral i was so shocked
play really good okay
hey y'all got a cigarette um we don't
smoke
[ __ ] off
[Music]
my most recent one was the roach titty
video have you seen that no no no
throw the roach titty video on please
i don't know if yeah everything's on
like there you go this right here yep
okay
do you think pbs you know pbs public
television that we grew up with where
they'd have to do like
you know they would do like uh
fundraisers and stuff and they would
give away like things you know they'd be
like the pbs uh
andrew lloyd webber broadway collection
you know if you are a excelsior member
at 35 you will get
not only to do i wonder if like they're
gonna have to just start [ __ ] with
online people
and they'll be like you know if you are
one of our presidential
donors we will give you the chelsea lin
vine companion
including the cigarette video i'm dead
take a look at this here we go
that big floppy titty
that went wild
now yeah i mean
[Laughter]
it's amazing what's brilliant about all
your [ __ ] is like immediately
when i watch it
i i know that you know exactly why
you're funny and what to do like a lot
of people out there have no idea why
they're funny and what they're doing
they don't know what their skill set is
and a lot of times it's because they
don't have one
but
sometimes people just haven't keyed in
on what where and that your [ __ ] is just
so good because it's like
everything is from that place like
you've connected with that [ __ ] just
crazy wild
specifically you that character yeah the
parts of it that you are taking from
your upbringing your life who you are
and then putting them out there and you
know these people exactly yeah and
everyone knows a tammy
everybody everyone knows
you don't have to be from the south yeah
it does not matter where you're from
everyone knows a tammy ever i'm from
long island i can know a bunch and i
think what's fun is louis c.k made a
good point about
you can't make fun of people if you
don't love them yeah so the reason that
um a lot of comedy about trump voters is
really bad is because the people making
the comedy loathe people they disagree
with so they loathe anyone who would
vote for donald trump
but that's why the the comedy is bad
it's hollow it's not good
bill hicks used to talk about the south
and make fun of the south but bill hicks
was from the south and bill hicks also
had love for the south so
when you have that
admiration
uh and you and you love people and you
genuinely like them and see like you can
you can poke fun at them in a funny way
you're making fun of your own yeah and
that so that's what i think you kind of
do amazing yeah thank you
you know and the same way libby i think
that like you very much love
older crackhead women who spend time in
parking lots
and you have that type of
a way to kind of make fun of the people
that you love can you tell the story
about what happened on tour because i
think it's absolutely brilliant and
beautiful
well
uh on tour by the way libby's a smoker
and let's give her a hand of applause
because
because i just quit but i'll go back
real soon and i appreciate that people
are out there still burning them try you
know i'm trying to
trying to smoke as many as i can in a
day and whether it's one pack or two i'm
trying hard but well [ __ ] yeah you're
making a little bread now yeah yeah and
i can afford marlboros it's nice isn't
it nice to have a luxury and see how the
other half lives
yeah when you're ripping into that first
cigarette of that second pack that's how
jackie kennedy felt this is how wealthy
and well-off i am now i no longer have
to dig in my car for change for
cigarettes i can go into a store and buy
a pack of cigarettes
and not have to check my account
i mean it's kind of nice you're tearing
up now and it is beautiful it is
something that itself it is kind of yeah
and i can even get two or three
at once at once and um and it doesn't
i don't have to look at my account
it's it's inspiring to hear that
because i know how how long you've
worked and how hard
you've worked to just get to that point
now you travel tell everyone what
happened on tour this is very funny
well i spend a lot of time outside of
venue smoking because we get there
pretty early yeah probably seven hours
early
because we have mental illness and we
like to be ready right
and i was sitting by the stage door we
used to get there i'm not even kidding
what seven minutes 20 minutes in second
after no i'm not even kidding there's
the audience was in the seats and the
theater would call us and go we might
have to call local guys and to do and
we'd like yeah you should have called
them already put them on stage we'll get
there we used to get there as the
curtains were going on so i usually get
there before the staff is even literally
so we're like
literally yeah
okay so i i spend a lot of time outside
the venue smoking and um i have a a camp
chair that people are starting to
recognize
ben didn't know what it came i can't
choose what a homeless person would well
you know just any person that's outdoors
right whether that be in chair yeah
right um so i set my my chair up by the
stage door where the green room was and
was smoking as i do
and one of the employees um i said hi to
him and he said hi back and then he went
back into the venue and told the merch
people which is uh chelsea's sister
and all the other employees of the venue
that there was a crazy street person um
outside the stage door and we needed to
figure out how to get her
out of the area yeah and then tina our
friend and other openers said oh no
that's our opener because that's how
tina taught it that's eye opener and um
so then i roasted that guy of course
while i was on stage you guys you're a
family here we're family oh yeah you're
a family and you travel together
and you all met [ __ ] somewhat recently
or you know each other a long time we
met on vine
it's been about how many years has it
been
eight nine wow we just met on the
internet she searched white trash and
found me here literally that's how i met
her so i had no followers none a hundred
maybe she had you know we weren't doing
what we were doing and i searched the
white trash and this this [ __ ] pops up
and i started following her and we've
literally been friends ever since even
before
before all this we've just we just
connected we're friends now
they would be great on are you garbage
the podcast i mean libby higgins you
should go on your garbage the podcast
it's a podcast where they test if you're
garbage or not
i want to i want to go on there i i have
a tattoo on my tit that says white trash
she does i think you're in
and there's a rose underneath it what
what now you know what makes you white
trick just tell us what what do you
think it is
you don't need seafood
i have a i have a lot of family members
that have slipped this that's one of the
things
so my family has a lot of uh back
trouble right um we love to talk about
our our disabilities lots of family
members are on disability and then you
need to grab a couple of painkillers
always for the back
nothing wrong with a warm fuzzy feeling
i don't have bad
as bad teeth now but we all have very
bad teeth now what does that come from
in breeding is it come from just not a
lot of money for the dentist um
that uh poverty but also our love of
soda so i've been drinking soda since i
was a very small child bottles
soda in the bottles
how young
remember as young as five and six my my
grandma making one of the first uh sippy
cups she took a old oyster glass
can or like you know glass thing poked a
hole in it with a drill and put a straw
in it would give me coca-cola as a child
and you love soda oh my god that's all i
drink the water that i had with you
earlier is the most water i've had in
months so you don't like water i love it
but why drink that when you can drink
sugar of course well it's part of the
luxury
it's part of the life that you live i
love it now
are you somebody who let's say you made
a lot a lot of money
what's your one thing you go i want this
above all
is that car
is it like there's some people when they
make money they go just give me this
i want one thing some people have it in
their heads some people it's a house
some people it's a car some people it's
i don't know some some people just want
a thing i know people where it's dumb as
it sounds it's a watch
is there one thing that you look at and
you go
i just like to have a car that that is
working properly and not yeah
that is beautiful any kind of car this
is such a fun and sad episode
because you know you know what it
reminds me of i used to i used to
telemark at photocopiers in staten
island
and there was a woman who worked at the
thing and her name was ida and she was
the top producer and she was an older
woman and i said you know top producer
you think she's killing it right she's
rolling in it and i said to her i said
so you know i said you're the top
producer everyone talks about you she
goes yeah i closed four deals this month
and next month if things go well i'm
gonna get a car
and i can stop taking the bus and i'm
like oh [ __ ]
that's how bad it is when you tell it
when you're telemarketing photocopiers
you're you're not even in a car yet
you're just trying to get so you're just
like i just like a car it's i think it's
because always in my brain again because
i have mental illness that the bottom is
going to fall out well so i need to stay
practical you're one of the funniest
people along with chelsea
that we've ever seen on the internet you
know and there's very few people out
there that interest us in terms of their
of their actual talent like the [ __ ] you
do is incredibly funny and anybody not
following you or not going to see you
live is crazy thank you
so nice that's so nice no the reality is
that being said you will die tragically
but that will only add to the mystique
of your life yeah you know what i mean
like they will find you in a red roof
inn and some animal will be eating you
yeah
but it will be beautiful yeah you know
did you always want to kind of be
in
show business or was it just that
everything else was so horrible and
every door was closed to you who are you
asking any of you uh for me
um
i always wanted to yeah be a movie star
if you if i and i look back into my um
high school yearbook and i forgot i put
this and it said like where do you see
yourself in 10 years whatever i was like
i'm going to go to hollywood and become
a comedic actress and i forgot i wrote
that that was all i always wanted to do
that but i just thought you know where
i'm from that doesn't happen to people
like me right so that's just what i
thought right um and then just
it's just slowly over time opportunity
started happening i started putting
stuff out there and
yeah it's i think i was meant to do this
like in a weird like in a weird you know
i don't get all spiritual and [ __ ] but
like i feel like this is like what i'm
supposed to be doing
i agree i agree i mean you clear you
know
i think you'd also be good at the casino
yeah i think a good blackjack dealer
yeah
that's not a question kill it at the
casino that's not out of question what
about you libby was this something you
always wanted to do i always wanted to
do
something in in like tv or movies but my
anxiety was so bad
that i i literally couldn't do it till i
turned 40. right well that's when they
say that's when the time is to strike
especially for women they say wait till
you're 40 and then give it a shot well i
just that's the hollywood adage just
wait until you're 40 and then jump in
with both feet that's why i had to start
online so i started i don't know if you
remember justin tv it's what twitch is
now [ __ ] it i do it's old school yeah i
used to broadcast live on there because
i was scared to do stuff in real life so
i'd do these little shows on there and
then eventually i got to you know vine
and then i started doing stand-up
and then um
my journey is a slow one but it's
happening
what do you tell people
that are because you guys come from
different places right i was born in new
york and i was kind of around [ __ ] like
this what do you tell people that are
just completely not you know they're
living in oklahoma they're living in the
middle of the country and they're not
you know they're they're maybe not
you know they're not in atlanta or new
york or l.a they're not around this
business
to any degree
what do you tell them you should just go
to the internet because that's kind of i
think the best thing to do well it's
like you know with what nowadays you
don't have to be in la to do [ __ ]
absolutely not you know and and my
advice would be just is just to do it
just do it just start and do it in the
story just do it right because i feel
like there's
no people like they always say the
gatekeeper but like you can make a tv
show you can make
videos you don't need somebody to make
this [ __ ] to cast you in something right
make it yourself
yeah yeah baby kills roach with breasts
lady kills roach with breasts
that's a tv show right there i just want
to add some succession please just let
me add this part i pulled the roach on a
fishing wire okay she did oh is that
really i was wondering now who found the
roach
so i bought it on amazon
you bought a roach yeah it's a plastic
roach oh and i or and i ordered fishing
wire fishing line and i just tied it on
there and i said libby i got this video
idea well you pull a roach across the
table yeah and she said absolutely and
then the people at the restaurant
actually turned off their music
yeah i said i said hey guys i'm going to
film this video and the music was rolled
out i was like hey they got trailer
trash tammy in there by the way they
would have given you the restaurant yeah
if you said by the way uh guys can you
shut down for the rest of the day i just
wanted to throw guacamole in my [ __ ]
yeah of course we will
yeah i know that i was like hey could
you turn the music off just because i
want i want to try and monetize this
they were like absolutely turned it off
and i smashed my titty and that was one
uh one take
everybody's tracking you now governments
private companies are trying to sell you
things and it's crazy you don't have any
anonymity any privacy what can i do
ben
well first of all you have to have a vpn
no
i don't well can i tell you about
expressvpn
yeah
expressvpn expressvpn
is [ __ ] great it dude it's an app and
it prevents your phone carrier from
being able to see the sites you visit
and sell it off to third parties cause
then they'll go oh
look fatty wants another biscuit
and then they'll try to get sell you it
right yeah yeah yeah they'll try to send
you treats treats uh links to stores
like that breastfeeding.com so you're
telling me if i download this app
expressvpn.com like let's say i go to
expressvpn.com tim dillon they're gonna
give me three extra months free mm-hmm
three months free yeah it's it's 90 days
it's free expressvpn.com tim dillon yeah
i mean it's a no-brainer how many times
have you clicked on something and it
says you can't watch this because you're
not in the area or you can't do this or
do that i mean when i was in australia i
was trying to watch the ozark season the
finale but it hadn't come out in
australia so we couldn't it was a whole
thing oh yeah that's annoying so if
you're on a vpn you could do that ozark
it sucked anyway but the point is i
didn't know that then
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-a
tim dillon that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
tim dillon that's what they say and by
the way uh you can do up to five devices
with one account so you keep your family
safe you keep your friends safe get one
for the wife one for the kid
and one for them you have your wife
your two kids
your brother and your mistress
that's exp or ssvpn.com
[Music]
i love earbuds but i like raycon earbuds
i like them better they're cheaper and
better than the other types of earbuds
right oh yeah much much better
that's what i think
raycon's everyday earbuds look feel and
sound better than ever with optimized
gel tips for the perfect in-ear fit
these earbuds are so comfortable and
they will not budge trust me
raycons give you eight hours of play
time 38-hour battery 32 hour battery
life raycons are priced just right you
get quality audio at half the price of
other premium audio brands it's no
wonder raycon's everyday earbuds have
over 50 000 five star reviews
they have three customizable sound
profiles earbud tap functions noise
isolation awareness mode
i really like these uh
earbuds
go to buy raycon dot com slash tim today
to get 15 off your recon order by
raycon.com
to get 15 off your order i use them you
use them everybody uses them
oh yeah i was listening to some great uh
lcd sound system i was listening to the
other day and some other podcasts i like
who cares
well i think it says
raycon
is great for your ears were you
listening to anything with them i don't
listen to what i listen to is my
business
if i say i'm listening to something
i should get thirty thousand dollars to
say it why would i mention anybody's
name without them too as soon as i open
my mouth you put money in it i'm gonna
say who i was listening to for free were
you out of your mind
i was listening to
fill in the blank buy this hey buy this
in the ad buy this moment in the ad i
love
i was listening to blip on my recon if
you want to be in that bleep eight grand
the first bleep the second bleep is six
grand
fourteen thousand if you wanna get
mentioned twice
i i do listen back to the tim dillon
show with my raycon earbuds oh good yeah
i mixed the show with my raycons i'm
glad
go to buyreadcon.com tim today to get 15
off your raycon order that's by recon
dot com slash tim to get 15
off our raycon order i use raycon all
the time and i love
it i love it
what are some of the good southern foods
we don't know about pete good
maybe they're chains maybe they're not
maybe it's places that are uh specific
to you you know what i miss yeah from
back home what do you know about brahms
very little but i know it's let me tell
you right now is it a custard yeah
uh is it a custard is it i know it's ice
cream
i believe it's a soft serve they have a
soft serve and they have regular ice
cream okay their burgers are bomb
see is it is it custard i'm almost are
you a custard gal
i like an andes custard i do like you
like andy's custard i do
yeah did i just fall in love with my
twins yeah i do brother
what kind of bra oh
okay so brahms
brahms is interesting
oh i miss it i miss brahms i think it
started in oklahoma maybe or yeah i
think it you know what it is it's just a
good burger yes oh
and i'm not a burger fan i'd rather have
a taco i'd rather have pizza everything
but when it comes to a brahms burger oh
you can't go wrong yeah you can't go
wrong interesting
we love me and ben there's a place in
montauk new york out on long island the
furthest point is called john's
and they have amazing burgers it's like
what shake shack should have been
and they serve my potato buns and
they're so good they have fresh ice
cream like you know strawberry oreo ice
cream and coffee oreo and john's driving
in montauk new york that's that's our
spot we love this oh yeah i like that
it's old school and it's just you know
it's really really cool
places like that in the summer there's
nothing better in the summer than
getting a custard getting a burger
sitting outside you know a picture oh
could it get a little bit more pixelated
yeah i mean you know if we ask ben to
work you know him and his wife will sue
me so i have to although ben go down you
know there is a nice one go to the left
see that sunset
get that one yeah montauk has some of
the best sunsets in the country and it's
uh well i'm just saying if you're out
there but so brahms now libby higgins do
you have a a restaurant a place where
you would go and cry
where would you go
what would you like in the whole country
i loved you know what i used to love in
when i was a little kid i was an actor i
don't know if you know this but oh from
when i was six years old to 12 i was on
sesame street multiple times i was in
some nyu student films and i auditioned
for a lot of things that i never i never
booked right and i would kind of go home
sad you know my parents would take me
out of school my mother would bring me
into the city i'd do an audition i'd
flub it i'd [ __ ] it up and then i'd come
back to the
penn station dairy queen
and i would buy a blizzard and sometimes
i would sit in the chair and kind of cry
into the blizzard while i ate it
and then one time
uh i i got something i was trying to
explain to him and he didn't he made the
wrong thing
and a sweet indian man who probably just
got to america he made the wrong thing
and i lost my mind
and i started screaming and i took it
and i threw it
in the garbage but i missed because i'm
a [ __ ] so it hit and it splattered
everywhere and i was screaming
now yeah
and i threw it
and the indian guy um was started like
laughing because he didn't know what to
do and i just like screamed it
and then i
i i just looked and my my grandmother
was with me and she goes come on and she
was like so she was i'm ashamed of you
she goes i'm ashamed of you
i'm i remember her said that she just
kept saying that i'm ashamed of you i'm
ashamed of you and then we went to the
long island railroad waiting room and i
just sat there and i still had like
blizzard kind of all over myself and i
just sat there in tears where was that
place for you
where was that for you
did you have that
where was that for you
the super sandwich shop is what it was
called in st louis take me there libby
very small diner right i love it the
super sandwich super sandwich shop or
sandwich or soup super sandwich super
sandwich shop take us there libby
higgins it was uh uh only you can only
sit at a counter thank you so much ben
he saw that i was struggling and rushed
well if he had set the mic up in the
beginning he couldn't get any if he had
set the mic up in the beginning you'd be
fine but ben likes to like his boss
likes to do it on the fly we don't love
prep
he's really struggling though thank you
what an this guy is just the sweetest
little angel you know everyone says that
who doesn't know him okay
he hurt himself
super sandwich shop in st louis on st
louis avenue you can only sit at the
counter my father would take me there a
lot and we got to see him on wednesday
nights because they were divorced
and wednesday was his day wednesday was
his day so and how many of you would he
take to the uh super sandwich shop uh
four of us
that's a lot of counter space my sister
my little brother
and my older brother everybody in the
counter seat everybody in the counter
seat christ almighty
and um so then we'd stop at the liquor
store to get
snacks oh he'd have a little he'd want a
couple of nips he'd he'd get snacks for
us we'd get a honey bun or whatever but
he'd get his snacks he'd get his snacks
usually a bush beer a little warmth and
uh we'd head on home to his house where
we'd watch tv what would you watch like
the cosby show family ties you know i'm
older so these programs were still
okay i used to watch them why aren't
they okay now
cause bill cosby went on a few bad dates
uh i'm sorry my headphone was not
working
hello
the super sandwich shop in saint louis
were you able to find a picture of it um
well he's not even why would he look i
mean he's not really he's not even
looking what was the name of it
nine times in st louis you said at night
it's no longer there but i'm telling you
okay but find a good pixelated photo of
it
old pixelated photo okay
what does that say right here
oh there it is
okay it's pixels
look at it wednesday night wow the
the higgins family was a family again
wednesday nights
gather your brothers and sisters around
we're getting honey buns and a bush beer
and we're going down to the super
sandwich shop because everything's gonna
be okay and then we're gonna watch bill
cosby and everything was okay right we
love to watch knight rider too that was
another great pro legendary legendary
program
program and then my dad would drive us
home in his uh
little station wagon and um
we'd continue on life the next day it's
a real tracy chapman song
you got a fast guy he actually has i got
a sandwich
he had a car called luck car
the car from where
that's what it was called le
space car that was the brand that was i
think it was a gnaw the model
car there it is
oh my gosh
oh my god that's like a joke
y'all
on the screen again ben for hours and
pretend i was driving
what color
it was white
with a black
car like this one with the stripe yep
wow wow i would just sit at it for hours
and shift the gears it was not on i'd
push in the clutch and just when you
were little yep pretending i was driving
yeah wow
yeah so uh good times and i when i got
older i switched up to a
um
your father's still with us no he has
passed on okay well that's sad because
you know it's
always sad when people leave but also
now you're doing great and it would be
oh he would love it he would love it he
would love it you painted a nice picture
i felt like i was there
you know what it was it was
there's something
deeply poetic about
the times in life
where
you're making the best
of a situation
that is not optimal
you know
and in that time you're doing what you
can to get through
and it's very very
there's something
even though you look back on it
there's something nice about it
even though there's probably some
pain associated with it
because i hear it and it sounds horrible
oh there's lots of pain it sounds
horrible to me like the idea of it
is horrible
and the reality of it is even worse
but but it
but then i i think back and i go you
know what you probably have some laughs
you have some fun
you're making the best of it
and that's what life is really mm-hmm we
also didn't have a choice when you're a
kid it's like you just had to go where
everybody took you
yeah we're going over here i'm going
over here okay that's a great point to
get molested by my brother okay let's do
this it is what it is right
tgif thank god it's friday huh
molesting and then super sandwich shop
you know thank god it's friday the super
sandwich shop almost made it well worth
it i will say that now you you guys
travel all around the country what are
your observations on this uh country at
the moment in terms of uh you know just
the way things are
you see a lot of places you travel a lot
you're you have that vantage point well
we go to a lot of places i don't feel
like we see [ __ ] right
you know we see the inside of a venue in
the inside of a hotel and you know let's
see her house walking around naked and i
see her walking around that's really
that's really
you know all we see do you do only fans
i do only fans but i don't do
uh porn or nudes okay i do i do she does
i do uh i do a comedy uh show on there
and it does well it does very well
called tammy bangs okay um
but i do vlogs and exclusive stuff but
no you know i don't finger myself on
there
well that's sad yeah well i mean i
that's you know i might
money
can can make a lot of things happen if
people stop buying tickets i will finger
myself right you know do you think
do you feel like
your life now
and the way and the amount of time you
spend
working and performing and
doing all these things putting up
sketches and
things like that
is it how you kind of imagined it when
you were
at a place where you wanted to get here
ah yes and no it's hard to explain
um
yeah i mean
because when i was thinking about it i
always wanted to kill people
like i always wanted to murder them and
torture them and i thought that there'd
be a mechanism that would allow me to do
that and kind of get away with it what i
found out
is that that mechanism is
the buy-in is so much higher it's so
much more money than i have
um so is there anything about where you
are now that surprises you
oh god
um no
no
i don't know what to say no i feel like
no man i'm just i'm just doing it as
long as people are enjoying it i'm just
gonna do it you know and people ask me
all the time they're like oh like how do
i get into it what do you do like and
i'm just like i don't even know what i'm
doing right i just want to make that
clear i have no clue what the [ __ ] i'm
doing i just show up and i just do it
yeah does that make sense it does i
don't know what i'm doing it does
no clue what's the next do you ever want
to do a movie yeah i'm going to write a
tammy movie and i'm going to make it
[ __ ] yeah um and i'm doing a carla movie
yeah we're doing yeah you want to be in
them i'll be in them okay absolutely
i'll write you a good character i'll
absolutely beat him okay you know yeah
for sure we have to ask him on you know
while we're filming so he can't say no
so he can't tell us no yeah yeah yeah
okay no absolutely um yeah i want to do
a tammy movie i want to you know yeah
that's my next big goal
i'm gonna do it yeah well good yeah i
mean you're killing it out there if
people love what you're doing where can
people
follow both of you if they don't know
about you and they want to know more
about you well hey man i appreciate the
clout yeah um because my you have it
already what are you talking about well
my instagram i had over a million
followers and it got deleted now why oh
really no reason
really really yeah and my my management
tried to get it back from uh instagram
for two months and instagram finally
just said no we're not giving her her
page but literally so and and and you
have no idea why in a million follower
count got deleted
no they just said they just said have
her read the community guidelines that's
what they told them
but i would i would literally post a
story of me cooking fried eggs with an
aerosmith song over it and it would get
deleted for sexual solicitation
i'm not kidding right
so i'm like you guys are psycho right so
i had to start completely fresh
we're all living in a sick world
god dude um my instagram is uh chelsea
lynn underscore c-h-e-l-c-i-e it's got
the it's got the check mark um i've got
a podcast called the viral podcast with
me and my best friend paige jen
and uh and then me and her [ __ ] ass are
touring the country so chelsealynn
get her on instagram
c-h-e-l-c-i-e-l-y-n-n
chelsea lynn thank you libby higgins on
instagram as well
yeah i also have a a podcast called slap
city with my friend tina d ball
yep wow
look at that gal look at me
higgins thought that was tim dillon at
first we're just having a good time out
here
and um
you're just trying to recreate the super
sandwich shop
oh my whole life what would you get
there what was the order uh fries with a
cheeseburger with mayonnaise
pickles and a coke and a coke [ __ ]
hasn't changed
that [ __ ] has that's all that's all you
want something that's different is my
daddy ain't here to eat it with me
oh god
don't don't look on that that is so
outdated look what is it that's my old
thing if you go to my second page i
think it has my only fan's link she's
like get off there
now i do finger myself no i'm kidding i
don't finger myself i do show tits i
smashed a cake with my ass a couple
weeks ago
dudes love her big fat ass look i cannot
answer dm's currently because dudes just
the the only thing that keeps me away
from only fans right now is the messages
yeah i just
now had what happened with the cake in
your ass i took a nice birthday cake
what kind um it was just a white cake
with sprinkles from like ralph's yeah
something like that i put it on a
chair
um
had my friend filming and then i pulled
down my pants and just sat on the cake
and smooshed it
to smithereens and i thought there'd be
more of a smooshing and it just flat
yeah i thought there would be more
i don't know what i thought more
smooshing but it just yeah flat as a
pancake and then i stood up and
then cut who wants cake who wants cake
well you're out there doing the work
yeah yeah and that's what's important
libby higgins subscribed
to see libby higgins flatten a cake for
six dolla those eight i have the
cheapest only five dollars to see you
flatten a cake with your ass that's a
good deal and then i will pay it lots of
lots of tits and mostly butts but
um we just like doing fun stuff on the
only fans yeah
we just [ __ ] around on there it's the
[ __ ] we want to post to instagram but we
can't pretty much that's
yeah for sexual solicitation yep i
cannot believe that killed that million
follower account yep how is tick tock
are they rough with you too or no um i
have a lot of followers on tick tock but
i have to really really really water
myself down right um because i mean
everything gets deleted on on tick tock
that's what a lot of people are saying i
have to keep it you know pg four million
people 4.4 million people 50 million
likes chelsea lynn on tick tock yeah
uh but tick tock's fun it took me a
while to get into
um i'm you know yeah i have to water
myself down on there but it's fine
that's what my only fans is for there's
libby higgins
baby hanging 212 000 followers go follow
these
go follow these women they are hilarious
thank you for coming and thank you for
having dinner with me i really who is
this by the way what is this
the first one no go go make a right okay
keep going keep that this person that's
me doing the
child filter that's me living my
childhood out and she was
she was curry she was curry gary yeah
thank you for skipping it
i want to see it's so dumb
she was curry she was curling her hair
with
occurrings too
and i say mommy
i want to
i want to
have a curly hair too
and my mommy said
you don't get
you don't have you're not getting curly
hair
and i said mommy please i wanna i want
you to curl my hair too
so my mommy says okay
you asked for it and she starts curling
my hair
with a hot curling iron and burned me
accidentally over here
my hat burn my face
so then my mommy says whippy quit being
such a baby that didn't burn and it's a
bobby that's it that's beautiful
mommy buyed
a home perm
at sarri's beauty surprise
and the whole term
it's called ogilby home
come home
and mommy puts it puts all the rollers
in and squirts all the uh
stuff on there and it seems real bad
and wait for the hair to get curly
so then she takes the robe
she takes the rollers out of my hair
makes puts
puts
washes my hair
it doesn't even look
curly
so then my mommy gets a hair dryer and
starts drying my hair
and the next thing i know
[Music]
that's so sad oh the next thing i know
is that
this
[Music]
oh this is traumatizing can i say bobby
i'm dead i can't believe you train again
bobby i know you like this hair no more
she said you don't get straight hair for
six months this will be curry first
thing
why did i make this i'm trying to tell
you this this is brilliant
don't get curly hair it's so disturbing
it's everything
he said this is a brilliant david
cronenberg film brilliant
it's brilliant libby higgins i mean you
just gotta follow it's stuff like that
where you guys that's longer that's
longer than i usually make i know but
you can't look away because it's just i
don't know what's happening and it's all
crazy she's got better stuff on there no
i know but see that's brilliant here's
the deal here's the third one there's
funnier stuff that she's done on there
what's amazing about that is it's kind
of brilliant in the sense that it's
completely insane yes well it's just
improvised too yeah no it's insane and
that's what i like about it but go this
one chelsea yeah
he's a seven but he calls bingo at the
vfw every wednesday
three
he's a one but he's got surround sound
a 10.
he's a three but he gets a hefty ssi
check oh 10
10.
all right he's an eight
okay but he won't let you wear a mini
skirt when you want to go out to the
tavern
tavern
tavern
he's a four but he's the captain of a
riverboat
oh
hey
all right he's a nine
but he still uses dial up
not the soap the internet
uh
ten not the soap
he's a nine but he's your accepted all
right now go down here and go go all the
way to the on all the way on the right
on the second row this right here that's
a
that's uh
that's great that's just a trend i love
it i love it libby higgins chelsea lynch
trailer trash county go see them on tour
go follow them on social media we love
you guys thank you so much for coming by
thanks for having us on of course i
appreciate it you guys are the best
finally we meet yeah finally we meet
we'll see you guys soon thank you so
much love you all right bye-bye